now a mega job fair is happening inside
the las vegas convention center
with the federal pandemic unemployment
benefits due to expire in two months in
september
clark county officials say now is the
time to find a job
if you're unemployed bianca holman takes
us inside more than 125
employers and more than 14 thousand jobs
this job fair
is getting folks back to work it's
amazing because i've been in town for 15
years and i've never
even during the downturn it was never an
issue with employment
but as you can see i mean a lot of
employers here looking for people
qualified people locally owned gen 3
hospitality company along with
government agencies
and medical companies need help five
thousand job seekers were able to access
laptops and printers for free resume
checks and employment
and training help all at no cost people
had interviews on the spot and in some
cases
job offers ensuring no lapse in
household income for many when extra
federal
unemployment benefits expire leaders say
this event will benefit families across
the valley
this is something that has taken an
enormous effort to get it organized
and it is paid off i mean here we are
and we're pulling off something that's
never been done before
the fact that we are providing this
service and to see people coming back
out a lot of people are still a little
bit leery about getting out in the world
so the fact that this many people came
out is a very positive sign
and the southern nevada health district
even offered free coven 19 vaccinations
reporting from the las vegas convention
center bianca holman 8 news now